an update on an exclusive CBS News kff
Health news investigation into a dental
device that numerous patients said
damaged their mouths Anna Warner spoke
with multiple people who say the device
known as the anterior growth guidance
Appliance or AGA was meant to treat
conditions like TMJ jaw joint disorder
and sleep apnea instead they said it
mangled their mouth and even they even
lost teeth
my front six teeth also became extremely
flared outwards all six of them instead
yes they were doing this I noticed my
teeth were starting to get loose I can't
bite into absolutely anything I feel
like all I have to look forward to now
is
treatment and pain and fear and debt and
um and I wonder now reports Federal
prosecutors have launched a criminal
investigation into the device according
to new filings in civil court cases
federal prosecutors are looking into a
possible criminal charge against the
device's inventor Dr Steve gallella his
company and the manufacturer of the
device we've reached out to the parties
involved but we've received no response
Delilah is also being sued in civil
court and in those cases he is denied
liability